these people don't want to believe that
Palestinian fighter Wadi al-hawa is dead
but he died from his wounds after
Israeli forces targeted him in the city
of nablis North of the occupied West
Bank
five other Palestinians were also killed
by Israeli forces turning Tuesday into
the worst night of violence in the
occupied West Bank in years
one of the bodies being taken out of the
area was burnt after Israeli forces
fired that the cart was in this is where
al-hawa was killed in the old city of
nablis he was a leader of the Lion's Den
which Israel says is based here
Witnesses say he was killed by drones
which would be a new Israeli tactic they
say that since on Tuesday reminded them
of the second Palestinian antifada more
than 20 years ago
tens of thousands of people bid farewell
to the five men killed in Annapolis
despite Israeli threats hundreds of
armed Palestinians came to the funerals
and fired their weapons in the air
our response will be earth-shattering
it'll be in the heart of Tel Aviv to
Revenge the killing of the five Great
Men of Nablus we'll be there for them
tension builds support amongst
Palestinians for armed attacks against
Israeli forces is increasing
those Fighters revived the spirit of
resistance in the Palestinian streets
again we are following the will of the
martyrs who said not to abandon weapons
the Lions then became so popular that
songs are being made to praise them
members of the den come from different
political factions and have agreed to
work together to fight Israel's
occupation
in a shooting attack two weeks ago the
group claimed responsibility for the
killing of an Israeli soldier since then
Israel has blockaded nabus
Muhammad abanja is one of those who
survived the exchange of fire on Tuesday
he's also a member of the Lion's Den
many say Israel's blockade on nablis
aims to turn people against the fighters
so far they've been only gaining more
support
the occupied West Bank